it's been 71 years since the u.s.
dropped the first ever wartime nuclear
bomb on Hiroshima Japan and then another
Anaka sake ending World War 2 the bombs
nearly obliterated the city's instantly
killing over 120,000 people now
President Obama who made a commitment to
a nuclear-free world when he came into
office will be the first sitting
president to ever visit Hiroshima but
his administration's made one thing
clear Obama will not apologize for
dropping the atomic bomb which makes us
wonder over the last eight years of his
presidency has Obama really lived up to
his vision for nuclear disarmament let's
not forget that obama won the nobel
peace prize in part because of what he
said in his 2009 Prague speech so today
I state clearly and with conviction
America's commitment to seek the peace
and security of a world without nuclear
weapons granted Obama did go on to say
that we may not reach this vision in his
lifetime and while he has made some
progress during his presidency he also
might be taking some steps back I'll get
to that later but in the meantime here's
what he did do in 2015 Obama signed the
historic Iran deal that prevents Iran
from developing nuclear weapons back in
2010 he signed the New START treaty that
requires the US and Russia to cut the
number of deployed strategic nuclear
warheads but this only limits the
long-range warheads that are ready to
launch the US and Russia would still
have enough nuclear weapons to
annihilate each other the president also
started the annual Nuclear Security
Summit which is either shut down plants
or converted highly enriched uranium
into material that can't make nuclear
weapons that's been done in 30 countries
and Obama has tried to get the u.s. to
ratify the Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty
which would ban nuclear weapons testing
although he hasn't been able to get the
Senate to approve it but it's one of
Obama's recent moves that throws all
this progress into question Obama wants
the u.s. to allocate one trillion
dollars to modernize the country's
nuclear arsenal over the next 30 years 1
trillion dollars why would the president
who has preached disarmament practice
well now the goal is to develop smaller
more precise nuclear weapons that can
target specific locations rather than
blowing up entire cities and if the US
doesn't ramp up their nuclear arsenal
one argument is that other countries
might instead and the thing is if
weapons are smaller and more targeted
that they may be more likely to be used
some say this plan could even revive the
arms race of recalled war so the
question looms what happens if one
country starts using their nuclear
weapons will others to and will we risk
a full-on nuclear war that doesn't
really live up to Obama's early vision
for a nuclear-free world